good morning Nick it's Tuesday so I want
to talk about chalene Woodley and her
beautiful hair but let's begin at the
University of California at Berkeley
where for the last couple years
psychologists have been engaging in a
series of fascinating experiments
centered on the board game Monopoly
because you know that's what
psychologists do with grant money
so all these Monopoly games are set up
but in each of them one player has a
huge advantage like starting with more
money for instance basically the game is
rigged but the crazy thing is that the
people the game is rigged in favor of
come to believe over time that the game
is more fair than it actually is and
that in fact they deserve their
advantages similarly a bunch of studies
have shown that rich and or successful
people tend to be the least empathetic
the least generous and this is
completely true Hank they are more
likely to steal candy from a baby this
is all a function of something called
the just world fallacy most of us
believe and in fact can't help but
believe that people in essence get what
they deserve in life and the just world
fallacy has the effect of making rich or
successful people less empathetic and
less generous because they believe that
they deserve their success and that also
people who are less successful deserve
that lack of success but it's important
to note that this doesn't just apply to
like Wall Street bankers it's also true
for all of us like Hank the vast
majority of people watching this video
feel entitled to own or at least
regularly ride in cars and yet if all
seven billion people on earth have the
same relationship with automobiles that
I have we would be totally screwed as a
planet not just echo logically but also
the traffic but the weird is the most
troubling part of this research is that
no matter who you give the advantage to
in these rigged games of monopoly people
tend to behave in pretty much the same
way Hank that means that on some level
people aren't wielding power power is
wielding people I've been thinking about
this ever since noted rapper and public
intellectual Lupe Fiasco tweeted about
it when man does harnessed power can he
only do so in the same tradition as
those who have had it before him and
thus yield only the same results as
those who had power before him I think I
often disagree with Lupe Fiasco but
those are very interesting and
provocative questions like we all know
the disappointment of electing a new
leader and expecting things to really
change only to find out that change is
sort of measured but maybe that's true
not only in politics but also at like
middle school playgrounds the monopoly
experiments imply that maybe in the end
individuals are just vehicles through
which power is wielded and Hank that
would mean that even very powerful
people are in fact not that powerful at
all they're just doing what power tells
them to do Hank I'm concerned about this
in my own life he said just noticing
that his shirt matches the wall right
but anyway I'm concerned about it
because I want nerdfighteria to be an
active and effective force against
worldsuck and I don't want it to be just
another community whose goal was to
become big and powerful but it's really
hard both personally and communally to
resist that urge toward power and that's
why we're gonna try to make things even
more transparent around here so that
nerdfighteria can hold us accountable
and so that we can work together to
decrease worldsuck effectively which
brings me at long last to shailene
woodley and her hair so hank Shailene is
gonna play hazel in The Fault in Our
Stars movie and Shailene is that rare
soul who despite becoming successful
stays weird and empathetic and just
wonderful
like she's often called a hippie by the
media but it's mostly because she cares
about ethical eating and trying to
minimize her footprint which by the way
so does hazel grace Lancaster anyway
last week Shailene had a great idea she
has to cut her hair to play hazel grace
of course and she's going to donate her
hair to children with hair loss an
organization that provides free wigs to
kids who've lost their hair because of
illnesses or burns and I'm gonna donate
some money to that organization so they
can make the wigs because I do not have
enough hair although some wives would
argue that I maybe have too much on my
face but anyway I thought it would be
cool if other people wanted to join
Shailene in doing this you need at least
8 inches of hair more info in the
doobly-doo
so to summarize Hank I hope we can be
aware of the unfair monopoly trap and
try not to fall into it let's try to
remember that the world isn't just
because only then will we have the power
to change it Hank I'll see you on Friday